let's jump into that first story this
one's got me hot
riled up i'm all angry check out the
story from intelligence or nymag
authorities say cop accidentally shot
and killed dante wright
this is an interesting story yesterday
we heard
that these cops shot and killed a guy he
got pulled over
so his mom says because he had air
freshener hanging from his
his rearview mirror they say that's
illegal in minnesota
when he was when he was pulled over the
mom says she heard on the phone he was
calling her trying to get the insurance
information the cops say get out of the
car
he says why they say we'll tell you when
you get out of the car apparently then
the mom you know gets off the phone he
puts the phone down body camera footage
finally gets released
it got released today i guess the cops
were very eager to put this out i guess
the cops
thought that by putting out this footage
it would
calm things down in my opinion no it's
only going to make things worse in the
mind of these cops they're like see
you have this lady cop and she's like
she else taser
taser taser you've got dante wright
resisting on camera trying to jump back
in his car and take off
and she's holding her gun she yells
taser three times shoots him once and
then says
holy s i shot him he drove a little a
little bit crashed
and then he died in the car so the cops
saying look we genuinely believe
it was an accidental discharge that she
was trying to tase him
there's a lot of issues here first and
foremost black lives matter protests and
riots erupted immediately
then many of these people who had been
seen at these rallies started looting
stores
i got these people hit me up on twitter
and they're like how do you even know
those people are black lives matter
there's like a photo going around of
them literally waving a black lives
matter flag i'm like come on dude
i'm not i'm not trying to besmirch the
good name of literally everybody who
believes in justice i'm pointing out
these people are protesting one minute
some of them go off in loot it just
happens
some losers exploit the whole system now
all's is happening in the backdrop of
the chauvin trial so things are going to
get absolutely nuts
summer is lighting up and there's a meme
going around where it says
how to tell it was summer 1990s and it's
the guy holding up punk's tiny phil or
whatever that
groundhog's name is and says to 2020 and
it shows a dude sending out a car with
his fist stop and there's fires all
around him yeah that's right
we know that it's getting warm outside
because the riots are going to start
and if these cops think that any one of
these extremists that are going around
burning in the city are going to give
them an
inch they're insane i think this lady
cop is going to go to jail
they're going to try and charge whatever
they can they might even get get her on
murder
three we'll break all that down but you
know before before i go nuts and just
rant all this stuff
i want to just throw it to you guys like
your thoughts immediately on on the news
coming out of these rides and stuff
uh well i mean you mentioned um
that she had an accidental discharge and
that was purely negligence um
she didn't know what she was doing
um the police frequently need more
training
yeah she panicked um you know you hear
stories about you know
police looking for or they're talking
about uh
defund the police and honestly police
probably need more funding for training
that's what i've always been saying yeah
i mean if if
if you are given the power over life and
death
of of citizens if you are going to be
given a firearm to
go out in the community and stuff you
want your police officers to have as
much training as possible um
you probably should roll back
legislation because you don't want
police doing
all the jobs that they're supposed to do
i understand that being a police officer
is hard
i'm not like a you know an a-cap dude at
all um
and it's a difficult job but that
doesn't mean that we have to
make uh make exceptions for when they
make mistakes you have to be held to
account when you make a mistake and that
negligence cost a man his life
for nothing because he was like we
talked earlier
he the reason that he had a oh so we're
gonna get the full layers of this thing
right now you're gonna go right for it
i mean you know i'm a big 2a guy so you
know
the the the reason that he had a warrant
was because he was carrying a gun
in violation of state law but in my
opinion there shouldn't be a state law
regarding carrying a gun i agree so this
is a sandwich here we got we got
a we got a libertarian he shouldn't have
resisted libertarian argument right the
way i see it is
here's what happens with this guy he
gets pulled over he didn't realize he
had a warrant
andy no put up his the the record of
what the award was all about
here's what i think happened they say he
was in possession of a firearm without a
permit
and he fled by means other than a
vehicle both misdemeanors
i think this guy got stopped at one
point and he had a ruger 45
and the cops saw the gun and said you're
under arrest and he ran and got away
i bet he thought he was clean he got
away the cops got a warrant for his
arrest
so when he gets pulled over he's
thinking like it's no big deal then when
they're like
get out of the car and he's like what's
going on you're under arrest then he's
like i gotta i gotta flee i gotta get
out of here
he shouldn't have resisted arrest if he
didn't listen so like
i guess where we're going with this is
he shouldn't have received any warrant
or charges simply because he had a gun
but if he didn't resist and he just put
his hands behind his back on two
misdemeanors
then a gun rights group or someone could
have advocated for his right to bear
arms
yeah you know you never you never should
resist because
it always ends with more it always
escalates to more force
well i never say never but 99 points
almost yeah it's your chances of getting
shot go up exponentially
as soon as you resist so fight the fight
in the court you don't
fight the police you're going to lose
and there's always more cops
right there are always more cops coming
there's backup coming
and there's backup to backup i mean it's
like it's like
like gta eventually the national guard
with tanks come if you kill enough cops
in the game right so eventually they're
gonna come with like the apc's
you are gonna get shot killed don't
fight the cops
fight in court that being said you
shouldn't have to have so many
interactions with the police you
shouldn't have to worry about
i had a gun and the police are going to
take me to jail for it
you know just for possession possessing
a gun so i say no
when i say never say never about
resisting i'm not talking about you know
cop says look you got a warrant you're
under arrest
i i the reason i say that is because
like there might be a cop committing a
crime legit
sure and he's like i'm a cop i can do
what i want okay that's different you
know i mean that's why i say never say
never
if you get stopped by a cop he's like
look i'm arresting you you're not going
to win
if you're if you're trying to get a
physical fight the smart people you know
you keep your mouth shut
you just remain silent put your hands
behind your back you get you call a
lawyer as soon as you can
and uh you gotta fight in the system
it's not it's not easy
the right to remain silent is a right
that is an
option and it's also your absolute
best option if you feel that you're in a
position where
you know where the police are doing
something wrong
explain you know say look i don't
consent any searches here's my
information
and then you don't have to say anything
else if you don't want they're gonna say
that you're being uncooperative they're
gonna say things to try and
intimidate you they're gonna say things
to try and make their own
job easier because that's what it boils
down to is they want their job to be
easy
because most of them look at it as it's
just a job i'm doing my job this is you
know you don't make my job harder
but you still aren't obligated to talk
to the police just don't say anything
but don't resist now we go to the next
layer of this whole thing
the rioting is the worst part about all
of it like well the dead guy's the worst
part about all that then the second
worst
absolutely i mean like you know moving
beyond that sure that's why i should
clarify too
you know after this instance we have a
bunch of people going around riding
destroying everything
and for what for wha why why why are
they going to be mobile and getting
stopped and stealing
twerking in the parking lot as they do
it it's not for justice no it's not but
is the media going to come out and be
like opportunist looters are destroying
the city
no because clicks yep
i mean if it the more the more
intense the situation gets on the ground
the more people are going to click the
headlines
the more profit the media will make this
is this is weird to me though like
you'd think the shock content of like
rioters burned down the city
would be the narrative that would
generate the most tricks for like uh
cliques for like a suburban family they
should be writing headlines
that are like you know crazy riders are
burning down the city how long until
they come to your house
instead they're like peaceful protesters
are shopping without permission at night
i got nothing i don't know i don't know
what they're thinking i
agree with you um the stories themselves
i
feel like are enough to get people to
click i think that the
the narrative that's being spun um
by most of your major media outlets is
uh is what they believe people want to
read
so like you said you know side with the
audience and i think that that's what
people really want to do you said that
you searched riot
on google search we'll jump to that
that's crazy but i
want to i want to get back on the gun
thing because like the one thing that's
really pissed me off
i tweeted this woman should be this lady
cop send her to jail lock her up
yeah and it was funny because all these
lefties were like based
tim like it's tim like hold on hold on
there's two things i want to say here
i i've bought a bunch of guns recently
and every time i go there
there's one very important thing that
every gun owner has told me no matter
what happens
you are responsible for what comes out
of that accident or otherwise
you can take responsibility that's why
it is your responsibility to
have all of the basic training don't
point the gun at something unless you
intend to destroy it keep your finger
off the trigger guns are always loaded
all of these rules
now i get it this lady she screwed up
she thought she was going for a taser
she yelled taser but she was holding her
gun heated at the moment she was
panicked people don't realize that
stress
she's still responsible for what comes
out of that absolutely
absolutely now here's the other thing
though because we were getting into this
i'm i'm extremely pissed about this
whole interaction
i don't blame the cops themselves for
being like he's got a warrant we gotta
arrest him
because they don't necessarily know what
this is all about but
like we mentioned this guy had a fort he
had he had a gun
and that was the grounds for him being
charged with the crime
what what what law did he break the
constitution says shall not be infringed
he didn't rob anybody and i'll tell you
what really bugs me as i'm seeing
conservatives post
this guy there's one viral twitter post
where he's like this guy would have
robbed you in two seconds because
he's got photos of him pointing gun i'm
like nah nah you have a right to bear
arms sorry
absolute garbage take the idea that that
that someone can
predict that that oh this guy would have
done this or would have done that
there is absolutely no way of knowing it
and
just because the conservative doesn't
like the way the guy
looks doesn't mean that the guy doesn't
have rights
he has rights for sure i do think
there's like photos of him with like his
gun and he's like pointing it at the
camera
and i'm like that's cringy i mean it's
cringy but i'm i
know that there are pictures of me
holding guns out there you know i mean
i'm a big
two-way guy i've gone and i've got
videos on my youtube page that
of me at classes training you know which
if you i'm gonna take one second and
steal the spotlight here if you own guns
get training
please please get training that's it's
the best thing
the most responsible thing you can do is
know how to properly
use your gun all right so you were
saying before the show you took a police
training
gun class oh yeah that's totally
inadequate uh absolutely yeah i i so
i've done
uh first first time i ever shot i went
to a range with some
other gun people well i should say with
one guy who was like
well versed in guns for a variety of
reasons he's a conflict reporter and
he's been in countries where they have
full auto just rampaging about
so that's where he gave me some basic
instruction i wouldn't say it was like a
legit training but i actually did do an
interview with a police trainer and went
and went through the full police
training
it's like a day it's one day so i'm like
sitting in a classroom they're going
over all this basic stuff they're
talking about
you know a good shooter bad [ __ ] things
like that and then they allowed us to
sit in on it and then afterwards we went
to their range
and they walked me through the use of
like all these different guns down from
like starting with like a 22 handgun
like
really easy for someone who's never shot
before even though i had and then
up to i can't remember what the highest
caliber they were they had was you said
what do you think it was like a 10
millimeter could have been 10 millimeter
yeah it was
it felt like it was bigger than 45 or
something something magnum probably
and uh so i shot all these different
guns and the reason i say was inadequate
so i'm like
dude i shot like 12 bullets you know
what i mean and
my aim is not good with these things i
was missing everything now long guns a
lot easier
to be accurate with but i'm imagining
like a lot of these people who went
through this were doing it to get some
kind of certification
and then you put these people out on the
street so so certification is not enough
the the big reason to go for training
i mean just a certification is basic
understanding and stuff the reason you
should go for training is is so that way
you know how to
operate the gun should you need to you
learn things like clearing your garment
if you're carrying it
concealed things that are practical and
and how to draw your gun and keep your
finger off the trigger while you're
drawing it because one of the things
that happens too frequently is people
grab their gun
and their hand goes right into the you
know their finger goes right into the
trigger guard when they're pulling it
out and then
they have a negligent discharge and
stuff this is something we were talking
about just before the show i'm like why
she had a glock i'm pretty sure it was a
glock and then we have safeties
and i'm like i wonder if this whole
thing would just be be solved if they
gave her like a beretta with like an
actual safety on it just
click the little safety up those things
are like like we said those are training
issues where
right if you have a a firearm with a
safety on it
again if you train pulling a firearm
with a safety and and
turning the safety off it doesn't make
it it doesn't take any more time
you know you don't have a you're not a
slower you know it's not slower to get
the gun out and stuff
um but it's a training issue if you have
a gun like that you need to train with
it
training is one of the most most
important aspect aspects of owning she's
going to be chauvin number two
probably you should you should go to
training every year i'm going this
weekend you should go to
one training class a year i can't drive
that point would you argue that the dude
got in his car and looked like he was
diving for a gun
yeah a lot of people i mean that's fair
probably what she thought he had a gun
no no no no no she was going for a taser
she said
she thought he was going for a weapon
and that's why she said taser taser
taser
i think it's definitive like a
reasonable person would conclude she
thought she was grabbing her taser
not her gun but it is fair to conclude
they thought he may be going for a
weapon because he had
his warrant was for having a weapon i
just i don't care for that argument
everybody should have a weapon because
the constitution says you can and if you
want to change it
you you change constitution yeah but not
everyone should die for their weapon
when they're being detained nobody
should die for their weapon
diving for their weapon when they're
getting arrested by the police
cops pulling you over you're getting
arrested you keep your hands visible you
obey you put your hands behind your back
you let him cuff you you keep your mouth
shut
you deal with it through the courts what
people don't realize when all these
people resist arrest and they're like
this is bs man you can't arrest me dude
this is the good side of things
in some countries they just beat you to
death right there on the spot in some
countries
they just put a cap and then they're
done in america oh no you have to go and
have a lawyer represent you
and you get to actually come out and
bond some place they're doing cashless
literally first world problems yeah as
much of a hassle as it is you're totally
right you're
100 on the money there it is first world
problems that you have to go to court
and go through a justice system as
opposed to getting your
ass handed to you or just being locked
up throw away the key
it's it's amazing that that we're so
used to this amazing system the founding
fathers had to die
for yeah what is it you might know this
better than me where it's like a certain
number of those of the men who signed
the declaration of independence
lost their fortunes were killed their
houses were burned to the ground
yeah that's what they fought for to
ensure that when we get arrested
we get to go to court they pledged their
lives their fortunes and their sacred
honor
yeah you know and and many of them died
and
like didn't have anything left of their
kids their houses were burned their
families were killed
um we know about a lot of the the
founding fathers that survived and stuff
but there were people that signed the
declaration that lost everything yeah
you know and died for it so
and and part of that what they got us
was the bill of rights which
is the right to a speedy trial right
that's that's the fifth i think right it
is in the fifth year quite literally the
right to a trial is that
you're going to get arrested you're
going to go before a judge and you can
ask for a jury of your peers
it's not easy and it's not always fair i
think you know it's better than
uh you know 10 guilty persons escaped
than one innocent person absolutely
but we strive for that and it's not easy
and there isn't justice but it's like
dude you're getting arrested
i'd be like man i'm sure glad i'm not in
turkey yeah really or in chile
you like how you phrase it you get to go
to court because in a lot of yeah
if you're lucky to go to court you just
get beat down or bro if you don't bribe
them then
you suffer yeah in turkey if you're a
journalist they just lock you up and you
don't get out
the oops yeah that's just going to jail
and then the saudis come and kill you
in their in the embassy so turkey has
the worst
laws for journalism and so i've been
there reporting a couple times
and the the pro-turkey people try to
justify it's like no no you don't
understand you don't understand
turkey is really good for journalists
the people who are arrested
aren't journalists they're like
activists claiming they're journalists
because they have a cell phone and i'm
like
so journalists likes sorry dude i i get
it i got your song so we see these
people out
it's one thing if someone's like i'm a
journalist and they throw a molotov
cocktail so another thing when there's a
guy wearing an antifa sticker is just
filming yeah push that guy aside he's
allowed to film it's an act of
journalism
but in turkey they don't care they lock
you up they throw away the key you don't
get a first amendment you don't get a
fifth amendment you don't get a second
amendment you don't even have the first
amendment in
in countries that allegedly have the
freedom of speech in britain
in the uk you can get thrown in jail for
for bad
facebook posts in canada you can get
thrown in jail for saying the wrong
thing
in the uk you could do something like i
don't know teach your pug to do like the
roman salute or something for instance
and for instance yeah yeah yeah and then
they'll lock you up and then
mark then you can teach your your other
pog who's actually a black pug to do the
black power fist
and they don't care at all yeah that i
got i got to say for those that aren't
familiar i'm making a reference to count
ankula
he did his first video which got him in
trouble was he he wanted to make his dog
a nazi his girlfriend's dog because it
was you know
uh the nastiest thing he could think of
but he later on after all of this he's
been through he made a video where the
other pug who was black he had it raised
its fist for black power
and it's hilarious and i got i gotta
admit the cajon is on this guy
going through the courts they seize they
try to lock him in jail he's laughing
the media smears him
and then he's like i'll do it again
but you know what he knew he knew they
wouldn't arrest him for the black power
thing
that was the point and the video is
really good he's like oh no the labor
party's coming as i hide the torah
i hope he moves to the u.s
i feel for people when they see like
american comedy and they try and pull it
off in their own country and get busted
by their
their cheap law enforcement thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you